[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THEY ARE STILL
ARGUING HERE.
WELL, THERE IS ANXIETY, THEIR
SUB SESSION, IS COMPULSION.
DONALD TRUMP, DONALD TRUMP.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
WE'VE GOT TWO BOOTS DONALD TRUMP
OUT OF THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
WE TALK ABOUT HIM, WE ARE
LOSING.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
>> TRUMP.
>> THIS IS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: IT'S GOOD TO FOCUS ON
YOUR OPPONENTS, BUT THIS IS
BEYOND CREEPY.
IT'S LIKE A COLD FORMED AROUND
THE EXORCISM OF A GIANT DEMAND
SHAPED LIKE A TWEET.
THEY SPEND SO MUCH TIME
THREADING ABOUT THE OTHER GUY,
IT WAS LIKE A REHEARSAL DINNER
WHERE EVERYONE THEY ARE TALKED
ABOUT THE BOYFRIEND.
HE LOOMS LARGE, THEY FELT TINY.
BUT IF YOU TOOK TRUMP'S
PERSONALITY OUT OF THE MIX,
THEY'D HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
TO SAY ABOUT HIS ACHIEVEMENTS.
THOSE ARE PRETTY GOOD.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAD TO STICK TO
A GAME OF WHO HATES TRUMP MORE.
>> THE IMPEACHMENT MUST GO
FORWARD.
>> I HOPE THAT HE IS IMPEACHED.
WE HAVE TO IMPEACH THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> I SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT.
>> PURSUE THIS IMPEACHMENT THIS
IMPEACHMENT.
>> THIS PRESIDENT'S CRIMINALITY
AND HIS LAWLESSNESS.
>> CRIMINAL IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Greg: OF COURSE, CNN SET
THE WHOLE THING UP.
NO SURPRISE THAT THAT IS HIS
MEAL TICKETS.
SOME REASONABLE NESTED SHOW
THROUGH.
>> IT WILL ONLY FURTHER DIVIDE
THIS COUNTRY APPEARED
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS WHAT
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN PLAY OUT AS
CALLS FOR IMPEACHMENT REALLY
BEGAN SHORTLY AFTER TRUMP WON
AND ELECTION.
AS UNHAPPY AS THAT MAY MAKE US
AS DEMOCRATS, HE WON THAT
ELECTION IN 2016.
>> Greg: THAT WAS NICE.
WHEN YOU HAVE 11 PEOPLE FIXATED
ON ONE ADVERSARY, SUDDENLY THEY
BECOME A FRACTION.
BRAVE, BUT SMALL.
THE MAGNIFICENT SEVEN DWARVES.
THERE WERE REDUCED TO BUMPER
STICKERS AND T-SHIRTS, NOT
PEOPLE.
THEY WERE GOOD BOYS AND GIRLS
RECITING TODAY'S LESSON.
EVERYONE TALKING ABOUT HOW ONE
THING IS LIKE THE WORST THING
EVER.
WELL, THERE MUST BE SOMETHING TO
THAT BIG BAD THING.
TRUMP IS NOT RIGHT UP THERE WITH
PUNK RAP MUSIC AND ELVIS' HITS.
THEY WISH THAT THEY HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT MOJO FOR THEMSELVES.
ELVIS' HITS.
REMEMBER, DANA?
THAT WAS A BIG DEAL, RIGHT
QUESTION MARKS THE I DON'T
REMEMBER.
>> Emily: I'M GOING TO LOOK AT
THAT TONIGHT.
>> Greg: THEY BLACKED OUT
ELVIS 'HIPS.
>> DID THEY?
>> Greg: I THINK THEY DID.
MAY BE A TO THAT.
>> Dana: I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
IT CAME UP.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE HAD A CONVERSATION.
IT WENT IN A CIRCLE.
>> Greg: I DON'T REMEMBER NOW.
YOU ARE MY FAVORITE WEATHER
PERSON.
>> Dana: THEY ARE TARGETING
TRUMP BECAUSE THEY ARE RUNNING
AGAINST TRUMP.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT TRUMP.
>> Greg: EMILY, INCREDIBLY
FAST.
>> Emily: OKAY.
THEY IDENTIFIED WHERE THEY ALL
WERE ON THE SPECTRUM OF THE
OBSESSIVENESS.
WE HAD THAT MEASURED APPROACH.
I ALSO THINK, THOUGH, THAT IT
SHOWED IN THOSE THAT PIVOTED TO
ACTIONABLE ACHIEVABLE POLICIES.
THAT'S WHY THEY STOOD OUT.
THAT WOULD BE KLOBUCHAR WITH
OPIOIDS.
THAT'S WHAT MADE THEM STAND OUT.
THEY USE THOSE MOMENTS TO SAY,
OKAY, BUT ENOUGH OF THAT FOR A
SECOND.
HERE'S WHAT REALLY MATTERS.
INCLUDING YANG, WHO TALKED ABOUT
THE LOSS OF JOBS.
'S BEFORE I THOUGHT WERE MORE
FOCUSED.
I UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE I SAW THE
MONTAGE.
I WILL SAY THAT I THOUGHT THE
POLL, THEY ARE REACTING TO
VOTERS, ESPECIALLY DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS WERE CLEAR THAT THEY WANT
TRUMP IMPEACHED.
THE POLLS SHOWED, NOT ONLY NOW,
THAT THEY WANT TRUMP IMPEACHED
AND REMOVED.
SO, THAT'S A PRETTY STEEP THING
FOR ANY POLITICIAN TO IGNORE,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU ARE IN A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DEBATE.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT PELOSI
SAYS THAT SHE IS NOT GOING TO
HAVE A VOTE ON WHETHER OR NOT TO
BEGIN IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
AND YET, HE SAYS, WELL, WHY
WOULD THAT BE?
THE REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING THAT
THIS IS A PROCESS THING.
IT'S NOT FAIR TO THE POOR
PRESIDENT.
NANCY PELOSI IS SAYING THAT SHE
DOESN'T NEED HIS PERMISSION.
SHE IS AN EQUAL OF GOVERNMENT.
>> Jesse: SHE DOESN'T WANTED
TO BE VOTED ON, BECAUSE SHE
WANTS TO PROTECT HER PEOPLE.
OKAY, THE POINT IS THIS, JUAN,
THE POINT IS THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING AT A
NIGHTMARE SCENARIO.
COVER YOUR EARS.
THE WHOLE THING OVERSHADOWS.
TRUMP EITHER BEATS A SOCIALIST
OR HE BEATS A BORING BROKEN
CANDIDATE AND THEY RETAKE THE
HOUSE AND THEY HAVE THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE.
RUTH RETIRED.
THEY PASS ANOTHER TAX CUT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT
AND THAT IS A VERY STRONG
POSSIBILITY.
>> Juan: I SEE.
THAT'S WHY THE POLLS ARE ALL
GOING IN THIS DIRECTION.